cuando tienes un problema de
espectroscopia en un examen normalmente
te dan la fórmula molecular y te piden
determinar la estructura de la molécula
algunas veces el índice de deficiencia
de hidrógeno puede ser útil para
descifrar la estructura de tu molécula
empecemos mirando ex anos aquí tenemos
un hexano con la fórmula molecular de ce
6 h 14 decimos que el hexano está
completamente saturado con hidrógenos
porque tiene el máximo número posible de
hidrógenos para el número de carbonos si
tenemos 6 carbonos 14 es el número
máximo de hidrógenos que podemos tener y
recuerda cuando estamos hablando de
arcanos y tienes n carbonos obtienes 2
más dos hidrógenos aquí n es igual a 6
tenemos 6 carbonos 2 por 6 más 2 nos dan
14 hidrógenos comparemos el hexano con 1
exc no ahora tenemos un enlace doble
presente y eso cambia la fórmula
molecular ahora la fórmula molecular es
6 h 12 tenemos el mismo número de
carbonos que
pero tenemos 12 hidrógenos y aquí arriba
tenemos 14 nos hacen falta dos
hidrógenos decimos que está en grado de
insaculación uno o un índice de
deficiencia de hidrógeno igual a 11 y de
h igual a 1
parece que nos hace falta un par de
hidrógenos
ahora veamos el ciclo hexano aquí
tenemos el ciclo hexano con fórmula
molecular de ce 6 h 12 una vez más
tenemos 6 carbonos pero tenemos sólo 12
hidrógenos nos hacen falta 2
comparándolo con el hexano nos hacen
falta dos hidrógenos nos hace falta un
par de hidrógenos el índice de
deficiencia de hidrógeno el y de h es
igual a 1 si te dan esta fórmula
molecular 66 h 12 aquí abajo está la
misma fórmula molecular y piensas en
cuántos hidrógenos te faltan para el
número máximo te hacen falta dos
hidrógenos hay un índice de deficiencia
de hidrógeno igual a 1 aquí tenemos un
doble enlace y aquí tenemos un anillo
con una idea igual a 1
una posibilidad es que tengas un anillo
otra posibilidad es que tengas un doble
enlace bien veamos al benceno aquí
tenemos el benceno con su fórmula de
c6h6 con 6 carbonos el máximo número de
hidrógenos que puedes tener es de 14 y
aquí tenemos 6 14 menos 6 es igual a 8
es como si nos hicieran falta 8
hidrógenos esos son cuatro pares de
hidrógenos el ideal es igual a 4 el pin
de h es igual a 4 y me gustaría pensar
porque el vih es igual a 4 porque si
éste es 4 tenemos tres dobles enlaces
aquí
y tenemos un anillo tres más uno es
igual a cuatro y obtenemos una idea
igual a cuatro aquí arriba tenemos un
anillo y tenemos una idea igual a uno
aquí arriba tenemos un doble enlace y
uno y dh igual a uno
también podemos recalcular el vih usando
una fórmula podríamos escribir que el
índice de deficiencia de hidrógeno es
igual a un medio por lo que hay en el
paréntesis que es dos veces el número de
carbonos más dos esa es la idea completa
de 2n 2 - el número de hidrógenos
continuamos haciéndolo para esta fórmula
molecular con 6 carbonos y 6 hidrógenos
sustituyamos esos números tenemos un
medio esto sería dos veces el número de
carbonos es 2 x
2 - el número de hidrógenos que es 6 así
que hagamos los cálculos sería un medio
dos veces 62 es 14 menos 6 14 668 por un
medio obtenemos un y dh igual a 4 si
tienes un problema de espectroscopía y
calculas el ide h igual a 4 piensa en la
posibilidad de un anillo de benceno
estando presente en la estructura de tu
molécula comparemos el benceno con otra
molécula donde agregamos un nitrógeno
aquí está el benceno y sabemos que hay 6
hidrógenos 1 2 3 4 5 6 6 hidrógenos
agregamos un nitrógeno estamos agregando
un nitrógeno ahora tenemos la anilina
como nuestro compuesto aquí
cuántos hidrógenos serían uno
4 5 6 7 tenemos 7 hidrógenos aquí
añadimos un nitrógeno y obtuvimos un
hidrógeno más tenemos que modificar la
fórmula para el vih así que continuemos
haciendo eso escribiremos que el índice
de deficiencia de hidrógeno es igual a
un medio por lo que hay en el paréntesis
que sería 2 carbonos + 2 y ahora vamos a
sumar el número de nitrógenos que
tenemos sumamos el número de nitrógenos
y luego resta el número de hidrógenos
continuamos haciendo este cálculo
un medio
por nuevamente tenemos 6 carbonos 1 2 3
4 5 y 6 2 por 6 + 2 más el número de
nitrógenos tenemos un nitrógeno por lo
que agregamos un 1 aquí - el número de
hidrógenos dijimos que eran 7 menos 7
hagamos esto sería un medio por el 14
más 1 es 15
15 - 7 es igual a 8 por un medio es
igual a 41 y dh de 4 con una idea de 4
piensa en un anillo de benceno estando
presente en la estructura de la molécula
bien ahora hagamos otro
comparemos un benceno con el cloro
benceno aquí en la izquierda tenemos el
benceno nuevamente seis hidrógenos y
aquí tenemos el cloro benceno
hemos agregado un halógeno y cuántos
hidrógenos tenemos en el cloro benceno
tenemos 1 2 3
45 sólo 5 hidrógenos esta vez añadimos
un halógeno y perdimos un hidrógeno
fuimos de 6 a 5 tenemos que modificar
nuestra fórmula otra vez
dh es igual a un medio por lo que hay
dentro del paréntesis 2 por el número de
carbonos
2 más el número de nitrógenos - el
número de hidrógenos y también tenemos
que restar el número de halógenos - el
número de halógenos que tenemos bien
hagámoslo para el cloro benceno tenemos
un medio por cuántos carbonos tenemos a
un 6 1 2 3
4 5 y 6 2 por 6 2
pero nitrógenos cuántos hidrógenos 5
para el cloro benceno
- 5 y tenemos un halógeno aquí que es el
cloro menos 1 hagamos los cálculos
tenemos un medio
2 x 6
2 14
tenemos 14 menos 6 por aquí
14 - 6
es 8 por un medio es igual a 4 obtenemos
un i dh igual a 4 y nuevamente pensamos
en el anillo de benceno cuando el i dh
es igual a 4 pensamos en el anillo de
benceno estando presente veamos un
ejemplo más si vemos en la izquierda
nuevamente tenemos el benceno aquí está
el benceno con 6 hidrógenos
y hemos añadido un oxígeno en esta
molécula añadimos un oxígeno
qué pasa con el número de hidrógenos
tenemos 5 en el anillo 1 2 3 4 5 y con
este son 6 aunque haya añadido un
oxígeno no hay cambio en el número de
hidrógenos y ya que no hay cambio en el
número de hidrógenos no necesitamos
modificar nuestra fórmula aquí para el
índice de deficiencia de hidrógeno
déjame ir aquí arriba y en marcarlo esta
es nuestra versión final para calcular
el ideal y no tienes que ocupar esta
fórmula todas las veces a veces solo
tienes que pensar en cuántos hidrógenos
falta pero algunas veces utilizar esta
fórmula te permite calcular el vih que
te permite pensar en lo que está
presente en la estructura de tu molécula
y entonces te enseñaré diferentes
ejemplos de cómo utilizar el vih para
pensar en tu estructura de puntos